Would you rather your child comes to you
and says, "Think I'm going to convert to
Islam." or said, "I I don't think I
believe in God anymore." Half of the
Christian population in the United
States are immediately going to convert
today to atheism if you press this
button or to Islam if you press this
button. Which one Which one would you
press?
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh to brothers and sisters. As
we watch what is unfolding today in
Gaza, we have to understand that
opposition is counting on us to lose
attention, to become fatigued, and to
move on with the new cycle. And just as
we can't allow them to dictate our
attention, we also can't allow them to
dictate the pace of our solidarity. And
part of that solidarity is going to be
there to rebuild Gaza short-term,
long-term. I am proud to give my
support, my word of support to trusted
brothers and sisters in the United
Kingdom that have started a waqf, that
have started an endowment to make sure
inshallah ta'ala that we're there for
the long run. It's going to be long-term
and we will not forget our cause in
Palestine. We will not forget the cause
of the Aqsa, and we will not forget
bidhnillah ta'ala our brothers and
sisters in Gaza. Jazakum Allahu khairan.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
So, Ben Shapiro was asked by Alex
O'Connor if there was two buttons, one
to turn America, the civilization, the
the the civilians in America all to
atheism or the other button to make them
Muslim. Which one would he pick? Let's
find out for ourselves.
>> and I hope it's not a crude question and
it's one uh sort of stemming
sort of stemming from genuine interest.
Would you Would you rather uh
uh your child
comes to you and says,
"You know, I I think I'm going to
convert to Islam." or said, "I I don't
think I believe in God anymore."
As a Jew, I'm I'm fairly indifferent on
the question. Meaning that my priority
is for my child to remain Brother, if
they asked me and said, "Would you
rather them become a Christian or an
atheist?" I'd be like,
the people of the kitab, like from the
evidence that we have from the people of
the book, at least they believe in God,
even though we know there's trinity
issue. They believe in the hereafter,
the day of judgement, the angels, the
books, the prophets. They have so much
in common. Atheists, they have no moral
compass.
I mean, I would incline towards
Christianity. If they said to me,
atheism and Judaism, I would go with
Judaism because they have more close to
theology when it comes to who God is.
But him as a practicing Orthodox Jew,
should we say, found it very difficult
to answer. Jew and which direction they
go from there is of is of much less
interest to me than than staying inside
the religious tradition that I believe
is correct.
>> Okay, maybe I should rephrase to say uh
suppose that, you know, half of the US
population immediately, right now, and
half of let's say the let's say half of
the Christian population. So, it's not
to do with Judaism and it's and and it's
not to do with your own family.
Half of the Christian population in the
United States are immediately going to
convert today
to atheism if you press this button
or to Islam if you press this button.
Which one Which one would you press?
So, I'm going to ask for more
specificity in line with the
conversation. So, which form of Islam
are we talking about and which form of
atheism are we talking about because
they come in various strains. We're
meaning like the if if if we're The
reason he finds that hard to answer is
because his loyalty is to his land,
Israel, okay? Above his religion, I
believe, okay? That's the reason why
because when he says Islam, it's like,
"Yo,
anything but Islam." And this reminds me
of the Jews at the time of the Prophet
Muhammad, Banu Qurayza, Banu Qaynuqa,
and Banu Nadir. These were hostile Jews
to the Muslims who when they went to the
pagan Arabs and said, "The pagan Arabs
asked them, whose religion is better, us
or Muhammad?" Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam, yeah? They said, "Yours." Idol
worship is that their religion says that
they should be destroyed like Amalek.
Yes?" They said them. And this is why
you find it so hard for him to see
just very simple. You ask me, I'll
choose straight Judaism, man, all day
every day. Judging from the premise of
no God or Islamic God, that actually is
not enough information cuz as I say, I'm
not judging people based on their faith
propositions nearly as much as I am
based on their behavior.
>> going to not try to interrupt this thing
as much, but guys,
one is believing in God, and one is a
denier of God. What What context do you
flipping need? One believes in God, the
one true God that you Jews even believe
that we will be we that that the Prophet
Muhammad some believe that he was a
prophet to the Gentiles. He's like, "No,
what you mean by Islamic God?" behavior,
which I think they base on faith
propositions. So
>> Let's say this is the only thing that
changes. You press this button, half the
Christian population
become convinced that there is no real
God of the universe. Everything else is
is is random. Whatever you might because
what we're discussing here is
essentially what what are the
implications of such a worldview? What
What are the implications of atheism,
which is just the disbelief
in God or the belief that there is Do
people have memories? Sorry, in this in
this hypothetical, do people have
memories or they don't have memories?
Because this this makes a difference.
>> They Yeah, they have memories. Okay,
fine. So then then probably Look, there
we go. Now he broke it. That is going to
Okay, let me break that even more. Let's
see his reply. In the West, atheism Mhm.
as opposed to a more radical form of
Islam. That's why I was asking for
specificity. Well, this is the button on
the right hand side was going to be that
they just become convinced that Muhammad
is is the final prophet of God. Right.
And And again, I was going to ask for
more specificity on that because I know
many moderate Muslims who are not
radical in the implication of their
faith as opposed to some who very much
are quite radical in the implications of
their faith. So but let's If you don't
mind, I I'm I'm going to set up your
hypothetical in a way that I think is
more clarifying for me, anyway. And that
is version button on the right is
radical Islam, like Taliban style Islam.
Okay.
>> on the left is don't believe in God.
Well, I mean, fine. You can do that. I
I mean, you see how he defines radical
Islam. He can't just say Islam. He has
to put Islam to radicalization. Islam
equals radicalization. I want you to
evidence for that. Objectively, where?
Nowhere. So, why does he keep saying
radical Taliban? Why are you putting
those things? I'm a Muslim. I'm a a a
author of Muslim that follows my
religion. I'm not Taliban. I'm not these
uh lunatics, whatever it is what you
want to call it, etc. Yeah? Okay, like
ISIS and etc. So, what why is he afraid
and he's putting this in the in in this
category?
>> I'm doing that is because that
elucidates that that elucidates a
difference that I think is being
obscured by the simple sort of belief in
God not belief in God question. Meaning
that the cultural heritage of that
that's why I asked if people have
memories or people don't have memories.
If people have memories, then that looks
very much like secular Europe right now,
which does have the cultural heritage
>> a lot of Judeo-Christian values in a way
that that would not be true if you're
without memory. Right? Would would I
rather that a child found in a forest be
raised in a moderate Muslim household or
be raised in a secular communist
household?
>> Or secular atheist household, if I may
say.
Again, from what tradition? Are we
talking in the USSR? Are we talking in
Britain? Like where where what are we
talking about?
>> about Britain. Okay, so we're talking
Well, we were talking about the US, but
let's let's say Britain. In in in
Britain, um depends on the strain of
Islam. If we're talking about like a a
liberal form of Islam, which do exist
and probably a liberal form of Islam.
Okay, good. Finally, he's admitted a
liberal form of Islam. Okay, why does it
have to be a liberal form of Islam?
What do you define as a liberal form of
Islam? I don't understand. What do you
mean by liberal form of Islam? Yeah? And
why is your category liberalism? Are you
a liberal? No, you're not. You're not a
liberal. Are you a liberal? You're an
orthodox. You are an orthodox full-blown
Zionist. Yes, you are you are the
terrorist version of Judaism. Like Jews
extreme Jews is you. You are. You don't
even class what's happened as a genocide
in Gaza. My friend, if anything, you are
more radical than at least these
nutters. Yes? Who have not committed
genocide. They've done crazy stuff
killing innocent people, mostly Muslims
as well. Yes? But they haven't committed
a genocide just the way your state does.
So, when you talk about liberalism,
where you where you get Why are you as a
orthodox Jew focused on liberalism? I
don't understand. Talking about a
fundamentalist form of Islam, then then
probably a secular strain of of Britain.
>> Fine. So, he would prefer instead of
radical form of Islam, which I don't
know what that is, practicing Muslims
who fear God and are stringent in the in
in in the the way of they follow Islam,
he would rather go for people who have
no God, no morality, you name it, I'm a
piano, I'm this, I'm that,
um and all of those things. Yes,
degeneracy.
Rather that than people who observe
Islam and who are saying that we should
be just and have just wars against
oppressors that are killing innocent
people. He would rather go with
atheists. Comment section, I'm telling
you. I'm telling you these radical
Zionist radical ones that existed at the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. And
there were those actual Jews who were
just. They existed at the time of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. They
did not they stuck to their treaties
with the Prophet Muhammad. The Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him get protected
them, went to war for them.
There you go. Now here Alex O'Connor
pushes him further and gives him some
very very troubling, disturbing, immoral
verses in the Old Testament that let's
see what
you know,
this radical Zionist Jew will say about
that. So let's see how when Alex
O'Connor presses him, let's see what he
has to say. And so when I open the Old
Testament or the Hebrew Bible and when I
look at the texts saying that
if you lay siege to a city, you can you
can kill if if the Lord delivers it into
your hand, you can kill the men and the
women but keep or you can kill the men
and keep the women and the children and
the and the and the livestock as plunder
as Deuteronomy says and and
in the very next verse sorry, the very
next chapter says that you know, if um
if you see a good-looking woman
and and I'm not I'm not interjecting
that. If you if somebody finds an
attractive woman
>> Yes, if you if you have to it's the
actual Hebrew, yeah.
>> then then they can take them for
themselves and if they want them as
their wives and they they take them
home, they shave their head, they cut
off their fingernails, they give them 30
days to mourn their old husband who you
may very well have just killed and then
you can take them as your wife. When
Numbers 31 has Moses instruct the the
slaughter of the Midianites saying kill
all the men and this time the women get
killed too but not the women who haven't
slept with a man. And why might that be?
And it says that he you know, keep them
for yourselves. And I I hear all the
time that this is some kind of
liberalizing process. Maybe it's
because, you know, these these people
wouldn't survive on their own. It is
some kind of protective measure to make
sure that you're you're looking after
them. If that's the case, then why does
it only apply to the virgins? That seems
a little bit suspect to me. You know, in
in
it's sort of scripture's littered with
these with these kinds of with these
kinds of people.
>> Well, again, so to to go back to the
sort of oral tradition nation part of
>> would would permit a and a proactive
immorality even if he can't for some
reason abolish the practice altogether,
if you see what I'm saying.
>> the
Well, no, that last point I don't see.
So, the the when when you say even if he
can't abolish the practice altogether,
well, Which already I think he would be
able to do. Well, right. So, the so the
the question is whether he can or
whether he can't. If he can't abolish
the practice, then the idea of wooing
people away from a particular type of
sin through a through a gradualistic
process
is known throughout societies across
human history. I mean, the gradualistic
processes are the way that that most
things get done across human history.
And by the way, the the the universal
practice, unfortunately, up till today
in many places in the world is in fact
the extreme version of what you're
talking about. Raise everything, kill
everyone. And that that sort of stuff
unfortunately does take place. Cuz it
does by your government. Hello?
You just Yes, it takes place by your
government quoting scripture and acting
upon it.
Prescriptive.
Even on planet Earth, even in the year
2023. And so, the idea of a culture
arising I mean, is this guy for real?
Yes, he's talking about Israel. Yes.
Israel has been committing that act.
from the Bible that not only about
slavery in its own shores, but then
about slavery literally everywhere else,
which is what Great Britain did. That
again, to to separate that off from a
tradition that also says that every
human being is made in the image of God,
right? Which is which is the verse from
Genesis. Or or that you have to treat
the stranger well, right? Which is
repeated more than any injunction in the
Bible, right? The there are these these
traditions that are that are at war with
each other inside the Bible, which is
why there is this hotly fought kind of
argument inside biblical circles about
all this stuff, which again is one of
the reasons why I said right up top that
when it gets to I can't just open the
Bible and interpret the text as I would
see fit. Well, I mean, there you go,
guys. You can clearly see he would
rather his children
be atheists than be radical Muslim. And
then when you talk about radicalization,
look at the scriptures that he's
defending and he believes in. And not
only that, they enacted on that.
And what's happening in Gaza?
What else can be said? It just shows you
misguidance. The misguidance is so
severe. The hatred for Islam is so
severe. They would rather their children
be atheists than Muslims who uphold
Abraham, Moses, Jesus. And I believe if
you were to ask this question to
Christians, not all not all
like people like No Logic,
Rotten Wood, Fake Christian, money
money money his wife in hijab after
saying hijab is bad.
Apos, the apostate weasel, who cheated
on his wife, the adulterer. Yes. I don't
know who he would he would even like
his heinous woman, his handle that was
given to him. She must have cried that
night. Oh no, give me another project,
please, not Apos. Anyways, so the claim
is what he can see. They would rather
see a world in atheism than Islam.
And this shows you how Islam is the hug.
Mom says, "And it is the truth." I would
all day every day want my children like
if they were to give me two options,
atheist
or Christian that they would like a
shirk, but
that to their theology, like even the
Sahaba, they rejoice when the Romans
beat the Persians. Cuz they are close to
us. That's what I'm going to say. Till
next time. Assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh.